[Music]
hello Carlos greets the prize with your
brief informative for today Tuesday
July 13 last night a person died in the
northwest of the valley the authorities did not
reveal many details about this
incident however they said it
happened a little before 11
pm  at the state house fire bank
located near traffic and was merciless
so far there are no leads on the
suspect or the reason why he
did it
moving on to other developing news a
man is in critical condition
after being shot yesterday evening
night in
henderson police said the victim
approached officers near sunset station
around 6:30
p.m. no further details are known about
this incident
a fire along
interstate 15 impacted traffic
throughout the night  tonight it is reported that
interstate 15 was closed in both
directions near the virgin river gorge
this is north of mesquite heading to
yuta no evidence yet  n of what
caused this fire but it is known that the
interstate is already reopened
for more details visit and started
diagonal dotcom in Spanish
now we pass with your
weather forecast a sunny day is expected with a
20 to 30 percent chance of
storms  after 11 in the morning
until night the maximum will be
around 110 degrees as well as there will be winds
at night have a good day 2 today
this is light of mine with its brief informative
for you although in Spanish
[Music]